if you're doing a transaction like that
and you've done it before you would take
necessary precautions was he holding a
Subway sandwich that was perfectly
intense
that's what we need someone poured
bleach on his sock
[Music]
so there's a dude right
he goes in the Apple Store on Fifth
Avenue in Manhattan
he buys 300 iPhones you can do that
I thought they limited yeah yeah me too
holy [__] did you sure do on Black
Friday yeah well that's like 300 G's
right almost 500 maybe he buys 300
iPhones at 1 45 a.m on Monday evening
November 28th why so many uh however
while he's making his way back to his
car
clutching on the three bags full
brimming with technology oh someone came
to [__] Rob's ass a car pulls up
quickly beside him two men get out they
forcefully demand he gives the bags over
to them which he initially refuses to do
but the men were giving up that easily
and one of them punches him in the face
and then runs off with one of the back
is this Inside Job sounds like in the
end the men get away with more than a
third of the total iPhones that he
bought making off with 125 devices
totaling 95 000 so you guys can't get
three bags from here
no I was wondering that too well guys
the getaway driver though oh two guys
get out oh two guys get out maybe one of
them was the ideas guy he said I'm not
doing it I'm gonna get my hands there
yeah he's not the muscle yeah you got to
do that or maybe the guy that bought it
was like a tug of war Champion oh he's a
big strong guy that's definitely the
second option that I was like maybe the
bag broke so it was hard to pick it up
now that's on the tug of war Champion
makes way more sense we already
established tug of war makes sense so
this 27 year old man is well known
around that particular Apple Store and
he likes to come in and buy up large
quantities of devices so that he can
sell them at his own smaller store
elsewhere I think he buys them at retail
though yeah that's weird what the [__]
but why would he run around with those
iPhones in a bag just like feel to them
in Manhattan how come I can't start a
cat 1 45 a.m yeah yeah
24-hour Apple Stores how come I can't
start a candy business by buying Costco
candy and reselling it but this guy
could buy as many iPhones as he wants
and resell
maybe there's some sort of authorized
reseller relationship that like they
have again I'm just speculating here
it's not official it doesn't say that
but it just says at 1 45 a.m he went to
the Manhattan Apple Store I didn't even
know they're open 24 hours like why'd he
go that early in the morning
or late at night the Apple Store next to
the jumbee and um waikikis open till
like nine or ten they're open late this
was 1 45 a.m so it's open 24 hours
they're like was this a Black Friday
thing I have no idea I don't know police
are obviously on the hunt for the men
who punched him and sold a bag and have
appealed for anyone with information
about the incident to come forward and
make themselves known it's not yet known
whether the man was specifically
targeted by the criminals because of his
buying habits nor is it known why he was
buying the iPhone so late at night
is that some kind of [__] insurance
fraud or some [__] sounds like it trying
to claim losses for it oh [__]
it sounds like fraud it feels like it
because like if you're doing a
transaction like that and you've done it
before you would take necessary
precautions was he holding a Subway
sandwich that was perfectly intact
that's true that's what we need someone
poured bleach on his sock
this is weird because if you're gonna
buy 300 iPhones and if he has a business
it's way more secure to just get it sent
to your business right so that you can
sign off for it and it all comes in an
unmarked box and you put it away like in
the back maybe as a Chinese guy and he's
like I'm not paying for shipping that's
true there's a hundred solutions to this
problem and he did none of them there's
a hundred problems to this problem he
did all of them versus like going to the
bank and pulling out money and then
going like I'll put all the money on my
shirt so the whole world can see it yeah
I got my money guys and I do this every
week at this hour everybody yeah like
what the [__] did this guys did they say
anything to the guy that he's pretty
dumb yeah they're like you're pretty
dumb oh okay they're like this is
Samsung country
they're wearing bag of hats too or what
like you think even the store if if the
store was uh in on it or at least if you
would think they would go okay you want
300 phones we're gonna put it in a blank
[__] cardboard box at least no the
store was in on it they're like you want
insurance for these no oh good yeah
that's what I'm thinking it's got to be
some kind of there's like a million
things you could do to make this a
better situation
yeah dude that sounds like so much work
too it's like I just bought [__] 700
000 iPhones or whatever it's like I
gotta sell all these things I'm gonna
personally sell every one of them I love
it you said 700
000. or what is that how much money
worth from 300 or 300 000 worth right no
just I gotta sell 300 000 worth of
iPhones holy [__] just to break even I
got something else oh my God I'm
surprised they even had stock that's
what I'm saying when you're buying at
that volume I mean you can't even buy
seven chicken fried rice is at Thai
Barbecue unless you tell them the day
before yeah you can't eat alone yeah you
gotta like give some advance notice so
I'm sure there's had to be some kind of
like hey I'm gonna come in there by 300
phones like come on speaking of Costco
you guys mentioned earlier yeah
when the [__] did someone say you said
it at 9am yeah dude I thought you would
be like speaking of Ty Barbie it's in
the same video it's 9 53 a.m you guys
said 53 seconds speaking of the
Chick-fil-A the way you guys are talking
about during the walk
it was in the same video okay but what
what and we're talking about reselling
here because he's a businessman right
what I found out is Costco is actually a
price leader like for it's a real
wholesale warehouse like you like I
thought low prices was just one of their
kind of sales pitches right and if I
went down the chain and I went to real
wholesalers in big batches of sugar or
whatever I'd get a better price it's
[__] Costco will give you really
[__] good pricing Joe I could have
told you this I've been a Costco member
for five years
so I could have told you this we sell
Kinder bank noodles at Costco
no but I'm telling you straight up
wholesale I mean Costco prices are
better than like a Restaurant Depot
exactly what so like like Cisco the the
but you got to understand it's also
familiar are you guys familiar with like
uh Forever 21's business model no no
okay so Forever 21 which I'll see other
people and make the same thing no no
it's not copy other people so it's like
t-shirts like Amazon style it's like
[__] [__] up the the the small
people if you can't hang right yeah so
Forever 21 would be such a large buyer
because they have the means to because
they have the distribution and the
locations they'd be such a large buyer
that they can go to anybody regardless
what the business or the product is and
be like hey we want like
5 million of these pieces let's say you
like made one [__] dress or some [__]
a certain way they want we want like
five million suddenly that's your entire
business model your whole One account
with with [__] Forever 21 is like 10
years of your business with like 800
retailers you know what I'm saying so
it's like you have to your entire
business is dedicated to them now but if
they go
hey
um you're not selling too well so we're
gonna cut it all off now but you [__]
changed your entire business structures
you've dedicated it yeah and then on top
of that too or if they go something like
this like hey we need uh this much order
like we're gonna put you in all of our
stores you're like holy [__] I have to
make like six hundred thousand piece now
and then like oh you made 600 000 pieces
oh you kind of made it wrong there's
this one thing off here so we can't buy
these anymore you're [__] so they're
like actually okay look we'll buy it for
20 of the price
you have no option you have to subscribe
you know what I'm saying so like they're
they're bullies I'm not saying Costco
does we love Costco keep on buying a
product here I'm just saying when you
have that large of a scale of uh yeah
you have Monopoly on something you have
that larger scale on distribution uh
from a global retail ship and products
like the margins are so ridiculous you
have to play by certain rules because
they have the power but I didn't know
they were passing on those savings to
the consumer I actually thought that
they were just [__] using that as a
marketing they're not passing on savings
to Consumers their entire business model
is membership prices yeah it's all
membership you guys [__] with our pay
and I don't even know how many
commercials I'm in now
because Bart was doing this [__] earlier
and it wasn't even 10 minute Mark Bart's
like talking about some great product
that he loves yeah now Joe's here Joe's
like how do you know they pass out the
savings to the customer there's hidden
ad reads in all these videos you guys
are in all the talking points are you
guys doing around us we don't even
[__] know it's crazy this video is
brought to you by Costco The Branding is
sick welcome to Costco I love you prices
is even cheaper than like an actual
wholesale place wow wow like all these
places that you have to be a restaurant
business to get like an account from
yeah like a half have a seller's permit
or whatever yeah they're not from
everything but like a lot of things like
[__] milk [__] sugar or [__]
coconut milk soy milk like all those
things lots of milk a lot of uh things
to make test milk how deep are we gonna
go to this ad read well it was all the
Talking boys at the head I said he's I
do where you get your bobo where you get
your milk where you get your coconut
milk
your savings are passed on to the
customer yeah you get your plastic cups
your straws what else can you save on at
Costco
hot dogs they haven't changed their
prices
just three chickens Optometry still good
very good oh yeah Optometry is fire dude
you get your eye doctor [__] there no I
don't hey no [__] I get my contacts
from uh Costco optometry I'll get my
tires from Costco tires oh you get your
tires there yeah dude it's just cheaper
it's cheaper I don't because I I've
already flexed fuel so I get E85 and
diff on my E85 app and have you waited
in one of those lines the Costco line
will empty your full tank by the time
you get there you know what you can't
get Psychiatry for that better help
use the code anime